[Music]
the night before the death race across
the wastelands is set to begin your
uncle the great inventors slayed cannoli
got kidnapped by the ruthless no side
gang the only way to get him back is to
race his coil runner against the gang
yourself win and they'll give back your
uncle lose and you'll forfeit the coil
runner and all his other creations as
the grueling race gets underway you find
yourself falling further and further
behind your only chance is to take a
shortcut your uncle told you about the
flux ravine gambit
fortunately the coil runner comes
equipped with emergency turbo thrusters
unfortunately your uncle was a notorious
tinkerer and the system still had some
kinks to work out
just minor things like the ignition
exploding the reactor leaking or the
oxygen levels depleting any of which
would end your racing career immediately
before his kidnapping uncle slate
determined that each of these critical
failures was the ultimate result of a
chain reaction originating in the
thrusters
he was also certain that while one
factor could trigger two different
effects and two factors could each
independently lead to the same effect no
effect is caused by two factors and
conjunction
however uncle Slade never got around to
pinpointing which thruster was
responsible for which error all you have
are the notes from his test runs one
when thrusters B and C are on the fuel
gauge glows - when thrusters a B and D
are on the fuel gauge glows and the
helium tank rattles three when thrusters
C D and E are on the fuel gauge glows
and the gravity' meter spins
for when thrusters a D and E are on the
graviton etre spins and the helium tank
rattles five shortly after the helium
tank rattles and the gravity' meter
spins the ignition explodes and the
oxygen levels deplete six shortly after
the fuel gauge glows and the gravity'
meter spins the reactor leaks you need
to use as many thrusters as possible to
give yourself the best chance at
clearing the gap without triggering any
of the three catastrophic failures which
thrusters should you activate the most
important thing to remember here is that
even if we know that one thing causes
another the converse is not necessarily
true for example this panic switch shuts
off the coil runners engine but the
engine being off doesn't necessarily
mean the panic switch was engaged the
coil runner could be out of fuel or
damaged or turned off normally we can
however conclude that if the engine is
running the panic switch hasn't been
engaged with that in mind one way we can
start is to work backwards from the
three defects that could knock you out
of the race
so let's look at slates last two notes
since they give direct information about
those the graviton etre spins in both
cases but the results are different that
means the spinning gravity' meter can't
be the cause of any particular
malfunction if it were the same thing
would happen each time so we can
conclude that a glowing fuel gauge makes
the reactor leak while a rattling helium
tank makes the ignition explode and
depletes the oxygen levels once we know
which two errors we need to avoid we can
make a table and use the logic of cause
and effect to see which thrusters
trigger them since the helium tank is
fine
during the first test run when thrusters
B and C are active we can assume neither
makes it rattle and from the third run
we know that D and E don't either
that leaves thrust
a which was indeed used in the second
and fourth test runs where the helium
tank rattled now what causes the glowing
fuel gauge from the fourth test run we
know it can't be thrusters a D or E so
is the culprit B C or each of them
separately the answer can be found in
the second and third test runs the fuel
tank glowed in both but B was activated
in one and C in the other that means the
B and C thrusters each independently
make the fuel tank glow
it looks like the a B and C thrusters
are off-limits fortunately the other two
are just enough to clear the jump you
rock it into first place and the gang
begrudgingly hands over your uncle he
thanks you profusely and decides to
celebrate your victory with a cup of tea
from his latest contraption if you love
the thrill of victory over riddles
puzzles and conundrum race over to
brilliant dot-org brilliant is a problem
solving based website and app with more
than 60 courses in math logic science
and computer science brilliance
resources will help you unravel concepts
bit by bit build up to an interesting
conclusion and discover deep truths in
unexpected places along the way visit
brilliant org slash ted-ed
to check it out as an added bonus the
first 833 of you to visit using that
link will receive 20% off the annual
premium subscription fee